joe biden and kamala harris trying to
put a unite on a united front after an
explosive report of a nasty feud between
their staffs tensions are reportedly
growing and their relationship is being
called dysfunctional kamala's people are
furious with biden for sidelining her
with all the crummy no-win jobs like
being the face of the disaster at the
southern border and biden's staff is
upset with harris over self-inflicted
controversies and how she tries to
awkwardly laugh off problems so
naturally the white house is spinning
like crazy and telling americans that
everything is just fine
i can tell you that there's been a lot
of reports out there and they don't
reflect his view or our experience with
the vice president i know that the
president relies on the vice president
for her advice for her counsel she's not
looking for a cushy role here she's
doing a magnificent job by the way in
that report i'm quoted as saying what i
believe which is that there's no vice
president i've seen that's gotten off to
a faster start than vice president
harris
so dana prime minister claine says that
he's quoted and therefore everything is
going just fine so this is one of those
things that's again where the white
house is expecting you to just not
believe what you're seeing um you can
tell that there's a problem here we all
know it they called a cabinet meeting
for the first time in three months last
friday on the day where kamala harris
was not even in the country
um and that and then that weekend is
when the stories started coming out and
it's not the first time all the stories
that ever come out about kamala harris
start in the house like inside the the
team this time it's like within the
white house and you could tell in the
cnn reporting that these are people who
are either close to the bidens or worked
for harris and didn't get hired in the
white house they might be bitter or
something but then the other thing that
they do is they complain that how dare
they uh defend mayor pete the the white
man over defending her more so then jen
saki's like fine okay i'll throw out a
little tweet and this just made it worse
i don't think that this is going to get
much better any time soon and i would
point you to brett bear's podcast today
chad pergram was on and he said
something can i just point it out to you
here he said that
they are preparing something in congress
that they have not done in many many
years where is it oh i'm sorry i can't
find it basically it's just as a podcast
it's about the process by which you go
about confirming a new vice president
ooh yes no i'm just saying i told that i
know so i i i just don't take it from me
this is on chad pergram our amazing
reporter on capitol hill he's on bret
bear's podcast i listen to it you can go
to brett's instagram you can find it
right there
and it's not just
quoting chad program on brett bear's
podcast yeah i know
and i think i didn't read it but i was
paying attention
and then it doesn't mean anything that
is it's like oh they're about to realize
what that means if they're preparing for
it because they're like what
if you if the appointment of the vp is
the next president well because then he
drops out so they can find anybody it
could be anybody but it also could be
this
she becomes president and then you have
to confirm a vice president right
it could be nancy pelosi yes
can i just say to me they seem like a
a couple that has split and they're
trying to behave in front of the
children do you have some experience
with this that that's i haven't i
haven't i have intensity they're still
going to share the house and they
they're still going to share the house
for now okay and we won't tell the
children yet
but we'll let's keep smiling
we'll go to the pta meeting and we'll
you know have the kids over and do the
play date uh and they uh
their marriage is irreparably uh rent
asunder mm-hmm now i i don't know it's
not as bad i mean she's not as bad now
as she was at guatemala maybe they are
having an impact so jesse don't they
deserve this oh i love it i mean joe's
gonna be 82 when he runs for re-election
his disapproval is probably going to be
at 82. he was supposed to be the bridge
to the new generation it's the bridge to
nowhere kamala's d-o-a that leaves mayor
pete he's 5-6 blacks don't like him
just cause you're popular you can't say
everything
[Laughter]
nice geraldo how's that
and then who's that with your finger
no i would never that leaves bernie
sanders and the woman from georgia uh
stacey abrams both not winners so that's
the democrat bench right there you know
that's why they're shooting so high
if they get her out by either forcing a
resign whoever they appoint will become
the democratic president because then he
leaves in a year right he's not going to
make it to 90 whatever 20. but i think
it could also be the other way that
they're preparing for the what if what
if she then becomes the president and
you have to confirm a vice president for
her
like that's what she said i think it's a
reverse
it could be i think it's a reverse but
it was very intriguing when i heard that
sorry continue um could you be smurching
different groups of america
yeah what happened to your new year's
resolution puerto ricans are very boring
we're almost to a new year so i don't
think he's tall enough to be president
there i said it okay he said i said it
all right ahead
what inflation the media desperately
trying to cover for joe biden's failing
presidency